so what is the situation right now
mm-hmm the situation is pretty calm
people feel protected where like this
island where we're back to the
single-digit of new cases every day and
almost all of it from international
travelers returning home and so people
are feeling safe and every two weeks
people can get nine surgical masks if
they're adult or ten children's the
social distancing is advisory there's no
penalty but people are just following
this social distancing ideas very
diligently and it is mostly just about
putting on masks if you happen to be
indoors and like around one meters from
people is very mild and the tourism
industry of course is taking a hit as is
air travel but otherwise everyday
industries such as restaurants and
things like that operate normally movies
are open but kind of reconfigure their
settings so that it's below 100 people
oh each in a audience so life is normal
early on I guess you know the my
expectation would have been that you
would have been a second hard-hit after
China what everybody expects including
us but which is why we started
mitigating last year whereas most
countries started mitigating dizzier I
am actually you know what the things you
mentioned you know federated learning in
the Church of privacy dissolved as you
say these are work great areas of
research where areas to you know use
theoretical techniques and practice and
maybe get less accuracy but it doesn't
matter in the applications the most that
you would be using but here this is not
the case right we're talking about as
you say single digits you want to know
very accurate information in a very high
resolution and so my question is when
you said it you've got you got it
through it we already did some legwork
because sergeant who get go through the
constitutional process and to see what's
acceptable not acceptable mm-hmm does
this mean what level of privacy is
acceptable or whether it's exempt
such a situation not to worry about is
about constraining essential freedoms
so during stars there was a case where
the entire hospital was barricaded and
people within there are forbidden to go
out including medical workers and that
of course is a constitutional question
whether like not endangering people
outside of the hospital
warrants putting as people essentially
within the barricade and the
Constitutional Court says that it is not
unconstitutional but the existing laws
are lacking in terms of the due process
is involved and so our loss then when
changes that explicitly spells out these
processes and one and I think the main
thing that you're concerned about is
about out of purpose use of collected
private information and that is in our
Privacy Act which is GDP are compatible
ish we're getting adequacy soon so
before we get adequacy I would not say
it's fully compatible but is it's very
compatible use it based on a European
Union Privacy Act before the GD P R so
it specifically said that you can only
use the collected information such as
the whereabouts of the phone of the
telecom companies if it protects other
people at general public from harm and
and or it protects the person itself
from harm and so in the constitutional
court ruling
if barricading people so that they
cannot leave a institution a building is
ruled constitutional then certainly
getting this out of purpose signal from
the telecom providers is constitutional
because it's used for the purpose of
digital fence and digital fence is like
in its worst form is exactly the same as
a barricade and it's almost always
better than the physical barricades in
in front of constitutional human right
viewpoints and so the legality of this
is not disputed at this time but even
when you talk about
about this saying that their law says
that you are allowed to do collect
information in this particular case of
information collection as long as it
helps protect let's say the patient
himself or and probably then there's a
question of whether even there there's a
restricted amount of information that
you can collect right because what's
necessary and what's not being to be
necessary
when we say out of purpose we mean that
we did have
we don't actually touch the data
collection face it is mostly they didn't
have processing an application face that
we're touching the telecoms are already
collecting the signal strengths and
things like that and so the amount of
data collected is minimal for people on
their home currency for 14 days which is
you know sending them instant messages
where they replied Twitter their their
temperature whether they show symptoms
and any suggestions they have to the
quarantine experience and that's the
only data we collect and and so it's
minimal and we can prove it's necessary
so what I guess what I meant it's not
that you're collecting new data is that
you're processing you're processing
everyone or processing the data people
people under the home currency and deer
clearly informed of it although there is
no constant process because
constitutionally there is no requirement
for a constant process this made sense
early on where you could control sort of
the people who would go into quarantine
it's a large amount of people like 50k
but yes the people went to the border
say now they're in quarantine and now
you want to make sure that they are not
leaving the quarantine or if they are
who they're meeting and those people are
gonna be that's not a question at all
it's just a question and that at that
point it was just a question of
enforcing the rules of staying in
quarantine when if they if they break
out of the quarantine of course the
automated system as you see on the
picture notices the county governments
the neighborhood managers the police
dispatch if they are went too far from
the quarantine if necessary and
of course we then use the digital fence
checking to make sure that if they
significantly overlap with other
people's phones then they may be also at
risk but that that is only if you escape
quarantine okay so this did so I guess I
mean like it say they went to the store
or something because they need to
exactly exactly so when you part of the
[Music]
finding out where they overlapped with
someone else well either by and then
checking that where the GPS is are in
the same place fine we don't I don't
think we use signals other than the West
provided by the telecoms so it's mostly
base station data and so it's developed
by this system is Demmel means I won
it's one of the major telecoms their
telecom developing it but it the other
for telecoms voluntarily participated so
they settle on a API so that's even
across different telecom providers the
system can calculate proximity right now
is so information obviously the
telephones companies have that
information question is is it the user
then you probably have heard this
particular idea of this scheme just
because it's probably the first thing
people come up with where your phone
generate some random numbers every time
it's in a location location and then
later people who have been in the same
if you get sick you know you kind of
advertise those yes so something like
that this Eddy application layer that is
the location history tool and is
developed by civil society here in
Taiwan but it's also been incorporating
data from Korea as well as from Israel
and so it relies on my application level
feature of Google called location
history which is for installing Google
Maps or a enjoy phone in general that
enabled location history tracking then
you get Google Maps timeline and so the
basic idea of this simple tool which is
the web-based tool is that it
automatically asks you to download the
last period of your Google history as
well as any API compatible chose the
first and and also downloads the
available data of specific cases so that
it calculates overlaps entirely locally
and well it doesn't tell you what to do
right it just shows how the contact
worked and in this way the history of
your local location history is not
shared it doesn't really leave your
phone is between you and they'd have
sources the information with this tool
because this was general-purpose it's
not is for people not under home
currency so so we do not have the
constitutional right to to force them to
share anything let's say they were
exposed at this point they are they are
at risk they are at risk of society
possibly because they can transmit right
so they wear a mask and get a check from
the local clinic so how do they my
question is how do you I mean we do well
we through I guess that that's how like
asking how do we enforce washing your
hands with soap we do not enforce that
but people do that okay so this so the
Assumption here is that people are going
to report in some sense else take care
of themselves or going now yeah because
don't people don't want to be sick and
we have a single-payer health system
they are not going to
for the treatment and the surgical masks
are plenty available so putting on a
mask protecting others going to a clinic
together check is the logical thing to
do if you know that you're going to be
protected and you're not going to cause
a friction so essentially what you're
saying is that the privacy issue that
are between the telephone company which
has the information anyway or between
googling you yes quarantine you know
they're part of the system the
government being able to track their
whereabouts
yes company has about the the quality of
these proximity checking and is there
any kind of feedback oh yeah yeah of
course every every person under
quarantine as I said other than their
temperature and their symptoms we
collect their feedback to the system and
so is continuously being updated by
people's feedback and there's a lot of
challenges of course there would be for
example spam spam us that masquerade as
the SMS checkers and we solve that using
crowdsourcing is called whose cause and
under technology or we switch to the
line system which has a verified account
it's like whatsapp and and a chat bot
can automate most of the daily checking
so that we free up some chores from the
local managers and there's also the
challenge of people simply going into
the quarantine not expecting to pay for
the accommodation but actually the
conversation comes after the
accommodation so if people come to
Taiwan but with no cash and so on the
local government need to find them
somewhere and so there's dedicated
stories and now hotels
dedicated for this purpose but the
volume was went beyond the original
expectations but
now we've been expanding such
accommodation places as the one so I
mean it's a daily improving system
so what we're describing now may well
change tomorrow by the Constitution of n
algorithms parents stays the same and in
terms of international collaboration so
there's a system in the future mmm-hmm
yeah but I mean our citizens can return
anytime right but currently we're
banning all foreigners arriving to
Taiwan unless for a specific purpose and
they need to be reviewed on a
case-by-case basis so so in this time
period the problem you raise does not
present itself but eventually of course
we need to solve that some thinking or
maybe with which everybody switched to
telepresence in an immersive reality and
massively cut down the carbon emission
what other thing that occurred it's not
only privacy related it's not privacy
related but you know when I read about
in the beginning is if you were checking
for symptoms of people arriving one but
as far as they understand now a lot of
people are asymptomatic your system
didn't see you know tech mark as going
into quarantine well if they're showing
symptoms there they're going to a
hospital they're not going to come for
insane right the the difference is just
between if you show symptoms then you go
to a hospital for currency if you're
coming from a
dangerous area highly risky area then
the entire airplane goes into a
quarantine Center and not the airplane
itself all the passengers but if you are
from a mild place then and you should
show no symptoms that you're put into
the dish no offense and you're at your
home during the 14-day currency but but
everybody's current ain't yeah I think
it has a lot to do with hospital
preparedness if the hospital has are we
in the computer science called
redundancy or high availability plans
and then you can afford to do that but
if you don't stand the hospital itself
need to go undergo reconfiguration and
certainly it cannot overwhelm itself
during the reconfiguration so again it
is a question of preparedness yes we
were not to prepare during the SARS and
we decided as 37 people died is 37
people too many and so there was a whole
recap of not just the medical procedures
but as I mentioned the constitutional
rulings and things like that and we add
there's there's a lot of publications as
well journals but a lot of focus that we
are working on now is sound useful
knowledge sharing between bilaterals
because every municipality to be precise
every outbreak every center is very
different and so we think it's very
useful to work bilaterally instead of a
kind of universal playbook thing yeah we
are so I personally did not have cause
with people in Israel but we understand
that our for example Department
cybersecurity and so on did you
briefings on many countries with similar
values but I don't know whether it
includes Israel or not we do know that
your parameter cited us as an example of
the digital fence
and that apparently has some
constitutional controversies watching
from afar but but I did not have any
conversations nor do I know anyone who
did have the right conversation with sir
five minutes me very interesting and you
know about all the other things and they
in a usual day like federated learning
with the French of privacy what we're
doing with fu see no more freaking
Christian you know what sort of thing
money laundering and which is very
similar to what you need here right
exactly so the information can only get
back no letting them know what you're
querying and so forth be very happy to
talk to you in the future
yes yeah thanks a lot for your time